[Musique]
bonsoir heureux de vous retrouver pour
ce nouveau 7,8 les invités voici les
titres septième départ dans les yvelines
de la course paris nice cette fois ci ce
sera le 5 mars à bois d'arcy
pour l'occasion nous avons interviewé
françois lemarchand le directeur de la
course
et puis nous recevrons christine
françois jeanneret présidente d'yveline
environnement elle nous parlera
notamment de la 28e édition de son jeu
concours le but sensibiliser les plus
jeunes à la biodiversité
c'est désormais une tradition dans les
yvelines la course cycliste paris-nice
s'élancera pour la septième année
consécutive du département cette année
bois d'arcy et rochefort en yvelines ont
été désignés village départ par les
organisateurs
nous avons interviewé françois
lemarchand directeur de la course paris
nice je suis avec françois lemarchand le
responsable sportif du paris nice alors
françois il y aura une nouvelle étape
d'eux mêmes étapes dans les yvelines
cette année oui et
très belle première étape avec avec un
beau parcours dans la vallée de
chevreuse une vie heureuse que tous les
cyclistes franciliens connaissent et
donc c'était moyen de faire un petit
clin d'oeil à 7 7 vallées par dampierre
parlez-vous de cerner moi qui suis
pratiquant j'aime bien faire du vélo par
ses parts c'est sur ces routes là et
donc oui il y aura deux tours de circuit
donc deux tours de 2 70 km 74 km avant
de relier l'arrivée à bois d'arcy donc
c'est ça va être assez j'espère assez
sympathique et bon c'est ya de quoi
faire pour les coureurs c'est vrai que
on va penser que ça va être une arrivée
au sprint on peut penser que ça va être
une arrivée au sprint et ce sera
certainement une arrivée au sprint mais
j'espère que les coureurs nous ferons du
pôle spectacles il y aura du spectacle
sur cette première étape le bien sûr
parce que si on a beaucoup de baroudeur
paris nice est une course de baroudeur
là on n'a pas encore annoncé des équipes
participantes mais on aura 22 équipes
sur les quatre dernières équipes sont
des équipes invitées donc des équipes
qui ont beaucoup de beaucoup de choses à
prouver et notamment ce sera sur six
étapes intermédiaires f1 intermédiaire
la hougue et des arrivées pour les
sprinteurs et bien les équipes qui n'ont
pas dû sprinter mon devoir de faire
quelque chose et la première étape en
fait partie il y aura également rejoint
en yvelines et rochefort en yvelines
donc très sympathique départ aussi à
rejoindre divine elle 100 habitants si
j'ai bien compté voilà et puis au pied
du château
et là on va pas on va sortir assez
rapidement du département par saturn ou
en yvelines mais c'est vrai qu'un beau
coup de projecteur sur 7 sur cette
petite localité l'an passé c'était
compter sur vègre
c'est ça aussi la deux
la valeur de paris nice c'est aussi de
montrer les richesses du département des
petites villes toutes les petites villes
peuvent accueillir une manifestation
comme celle-ci
tous les sports les gones les grands
sports le football de déplace pas tandis
que l'on se déplace partout donc ça
c'est parfait donc voir au choix rennie
line et bien c'est un coup de projecteur
aussi pour cette petite commune au
niveau des coureurs il y aura les
meilleurs mondiaux et français il y aura
normalement les meilleurs mondiaux les
meilleurs français donc il ya aussi une
autre épreuve en italie qui démarre
trois jours après tirreno adriatico
mais on ne se plaint pas sûr sur la
qualité des coureurs donc les principaux
contador richie porte et on attend on
attend la présence du vainqueur sortant
guérenne thomass et on à romain bardet
un haras rue mary julian alaphilippe on
aura d'autres têtes d'affiché aussi dit
sprinteur andre greipel qui sera présent
marcel kittel donc on aura aussi des
sprinteurs nacer bouhanni arnaud démare
je vais en oublier donc je vais arrêter
mais on a on a toujours un beau plateau
pourquoi parce que il faut qu'on
proposait des beaux parcours pour
proposer vos parcours il faut qu'on ait
des baies ligne d'arrivée
et pour proposer l'idée qu'on est
d'accord des collectivités l'accord des
collectivités et bien il faut proposer
donc voilà terrain de jeu c'est la route
donc quand on affiche mais tout ça mais
on fait une présentation comme
aujourd'hui et puis on est satisfait
parce que vous avez un favori sur ce
paris nice bat favori mois je
souhaiterais pourquoi pas que ce soit le
berthod contador parce qu'il s'est bien
battu jusqu'à la dernière étape l'an
passé après un favori
j'aimerais que ce soit un coureur
français aussi à l'ats philippe romain
bardet pourquoi pas même si ces
objectifs seront beaucoup plus tard mais
non je viens de là philippe je sois bien
je serai bien le paris nice 2010 est
s'élancera le 5 mars de bois d'arcy et
nous recevons crise christine françoise
jeanneret présidente divine
environnement a des qui nous allons
parler de la 28e édition de son jeu
concours
le but du jeu est de sensibiliser les
plus jeunes à la biodiversité
il se déroule du 5 janvier au 1er avril
2017 et s'adresse aux jeunes entre 5 et
15 ans bonsoir madame gênerait alors
dites moi un peu plus sur ce jeu voilà
alors nous avons créé ce jeu
effectivement il y a déjà un certain
temps car nous pensons que
l'environnement dont on parle de plus en
plus est quelque chose qui doit
s'apprendre que c'est pas quelque chose
qu'on invente
il ya des constantes en matière de bio
diversité de climats de pollution qui
sont des éléments essentiels
donc nous avons cherché à travers ce
cycle d'éducation à l'environnement de
donner aux scolaires et aux enseignants
un support qui leur permet de réfléchir
autour d'un thème donné et les marquis
est le thème de cette année est un des
éléments très importants au niveau de la
biodiversité c'est la 28e édition tout à
fond vous avez toujours la même ferveur
pourquoi expliquez moi c'est les retours
parce que je pense je suis très attaché
depuis des années si vous voulez à ces
questions concernant l'environnement
je pense que c'est très important
apprendre les gestes qui font qu'on
économise l'eau en ne laissant pas
indéfiniment la douche coulé en
recyclant en jetant ski la canette qui
le papier dans un secteur différent
ce sont des éléments très importants et
pour moi qui doivent être appris comme
beaucoup d'autres choses et ce pourquoi
nous avons créé ce support votre choix
cette année c
benamar la masse voilà aussi sur les
fiches sur la fiche et sur les bulletins
qui sont envoyées par l'éducation
nationale le ministère de la cohésion
sociale et le département dans
l'ensemble des eaux à l'ensemble des
scolaires du département
et nous avons aussi un partenaire
extrêmement important qui est la sncf
car comme nous sommes tous bénévoles
nous n'avions pas de moyens de diffusion
grand public grâce à la sncf dans les
gares sncf du département c'est à dire
les deux circuits dont parnasse
rambouillet et saint lazare mantes
les bulletins sont mis à disposition du
public
vous trouvez que les plus jeunes sont
assez sensibilisés aujourd'hui il ya
encore beaucoup de travail à faire je
pense que c'est comme dans beaucoup de
choses il ya encore beaucoup de travail
à faire et quelquefois des gestes
simples qui sont salutaires se brosser
les dents
si vous voulez au lieu de laisser couler
le robinet si vous mettez de l'autre
dans un verre et que vous vous brossez
les dents vous économiser l'eau qui est
aussi bravo vous aurez une bonne note
mais voilà et si vous voulez il ya des
petites choses alors évidemment il ya
des choses beaucoup plus complexes comme
le climat l'eau les questions d'eau qui
sont éminemment importante la pollution
aussi mais ce qu'on souhaite apprendre
aux enfants c'est les confronter à la
réalité
nous avons eu la chance cette année
d'être accueillis par pour les journées
de formation par thoiry et par le compte
de la panouse parce que il y a à thoiry
qui a été créée par eu une
maison si vous voulez où justement on
peut voir tous ces petits animaux qui
peuplent nos mares et qui sont tellement
importants pour la biodiversité
voilà on va essayer de les attirer ces
jeunes entre 5 et 15 ans tout un jeu
concours
alors c'est possible ou pas alors c'est
un jeu concours le but nous essayons
qu'il soit le plus facile possible car
le but n'est pas la difficulté mais de
faire réfléchir autour d'un thème donné
vous avez la gentillesse de d'en faire
part de nous interviewer les nouvelles
sont nos partenaires et chaque semaine
dans le journal des nouvelles il y a une
petite aide si vous me le permettez pour
justement rendre plus facile de remplir
cette fameuse grille et nous avons aussi
sur le site d'yvelines environnement des
fiches qui nous ont été données par nos
partenaires scientifiques qui sont loués
nef l'éducation nationale et l'inra et
qui sont à disposition aussi pour une
meilleure compréhension des questions et
de ce que nous demandons par rapport à
la vie des marques excuse alors par
rapport à la vie démarre cette année
mais si vous voulez nous avons traité
tous les sujets qui vont apprendre de
plus bas sur la vie démarre moi je ne
connaissais pas voilà bah voilà bah
voilà et sans doute quand vous êtes
promener en forêt vous êtes vous
promener à côté d'une marge de beaucoup
moustiques
c'est vrai c'est vrai mais tout est
important mais tout est important parce
que si vous voulez cette biodiversité et
ce cycle de la nature
n'oubliez pas que les oiseaux se
nourrissent des insectes que les oiseaux
les certains rongeurs aussi si vous
voulez ont un rôle éminemment important
les batraciens aussi et c'est ce grand
cycle de la nature dans son ensemble que
l'on peut retrouver à partir du mar au
royaume vous le dites vous même
avec humilité vous êtes passé à côté
démarre sans jamais vous rendre compte
que ça avait une importance donc on
voudrait si vous voulez la prochaine
fois que vous irez en forêt et que vous
passerez à côté d'une mare que vous vous
arrêtiez et qui vont regardiez ce qui se
passe dans une mare et voix je ferai
attention voilà premier juré et
dites-moi laisser la 38e édition wii les
quels sont les retours que vous avez
aussi bien des enfants que des parents
alors en général balle les enfants qui
participent sont très heureux et aussi
la finalité des prix ne sont pas si vous
voulez une visite à disney non pas que
je critique du tout disney mais sont des
visites de sites d'intérêt écologique
autre élément très important pour nous
nos liens avec la chambre de commerce
qui est aussi notre partenaire et nous
voulons aussi faire comprendre aux
enfants que l'environnement ce sont les
industriels qui parfois sont trop
modestes et ne mettent pas tellement en
avant tout ce qu'ils font pour
l'environnement et donc ses ports aussi
leur montrer que tout est un ensemble
ok vous m'avez aussi parlé d'une
exposition alors tout à fait nouvelle
peut-on tout gagné la ferme la ferme du
manège c'est à dire les services de
l'éducation nationale plus la section
sciences de l'éducation nationale
organise une grande exposition à la
ferme du manet dans le cadre aussi de ce
cycle d'éducation à l'environnement et
je vous convie tous si cela peut vous
aider à aller visiter cette exposition
qui a lieu du 8
du 6 au 11 mars prochain ok très bien et
pour finir allez c'est à vous maintenant
poussé ces jeunes de 5 à 15 ans a
participé à ce jeu-concours pourquoi il
devrait faire eh bien il devrait le
faire parce que je pense que c'est
important pour eux c'est une des
connaissances à acquérir sur le plan
scolaire je trouve que l'environnement
est pour moi quelque chose d'aussi
important qu éventuellement une langue
étrangère
le français les mathématiques l'histoire
je trouve que c'est une des composantes
pour moi de l'éducation et c'est pour ça
et puis alors il ya une grande remise
des prix très solennelle au palais des
congrès où chacun est récompensé et donc
si vous voulez je pense que c'est aussi
satisfaisant et ils ont tous des prix
qui sont soit des visites de sites parc
comme la réserve de saint quentin qui
est proche pour vous comme aussi à
rambouillet le nf qui organise des
visites et donc voilà tout ce que je
pouvais vous en dire et merci eh bien
merci à vous d'être venu sur le plateau
de 7 800 invités et puis je pense que
ils nous ont regardés et ils vont
participer au jeu concours en tout cas
l'émission est finie bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]